ERIC SCHMIDT: Google is about
starting conversations with
data and trying to start with
some basic scientific
observations and getting
the measurements right.
And I think that's one of the
things that you guys could be
proudest of, is that you started
from a fact basis as
opposed to an emotional one.
Robert, do you want to
introduce everybody?
ROBERT STONE: I'm
Robert Stone.
I'm the producer and director
of the film.
This is Stewart Brand, Gwyneth
Cravens, Mark Lynas, Michael
Shellenberger, all of whom
started off being very
anti-nuclear.
MICHAEL SHELLENBERGER: The view
that we all sort of came
to in our own ways is that
cheap, clean energy is
arguably the most important
thing from a human development
and an environmental
perspective.
From cheap, clean energy,
everybody in the world can
have medicines.
They can have clean water.
They can have longer lifespans,
healthier lives.
And you can use that energy,
then, to grow more food on
less land, letting more of
nature go back to wilderness.
This is why Bill Gates says
cheap, clean energy is the
biggest human development goal
of the 21st century.
STEWART BRAND: The most energy
efficient way to live is right
on the edge of desperate
poverty.
In the favelas and slums of the
world, there are people
who are really using very, very
little material and very,
very little energy.
They are so green, and they
are so eager to stop being
that kind of green.
And the main economic and
demographic event in the world
now is people are getting
the hell out of poverty
all over the world.
Where you've been traveling,
I think you're seeing this.
And in even the most desperate
slums, people are in those
desperate slums, rather than
back in the village, because
in the village, they
were stuck.
In town, they've got a shot.
And they're taking that shot.
And you'll see wires everywhere,
because they need
electricity to do all
the stuff that means
being part of a city.
But as you're finding in
Pakistan and elsewhere, if
it's uneven, if it's unreliable
electricity, then
everything slows down.
School slows down.
Medicine slows down.
MICHAEL SHELLENBERGER: If you
can get the one billion
richest people in the world to
cut their energy consumption
in half, to get the other 7 or
8 billion people up to that
standard, you're still going
to have to triple or maybe
quadruple global energy
consumption.
So the math actually
doesn't work out.
MARK LYNAS: The fact that we've
got enough mined uranium
and spent fuel already to run
the entire country at 80
gigawatts, which is its current
energy consumption,
for 500 years is interesting.
And you could run the US for a
thousand years on stuff that's
already sitting around in
junkyards in Kentucky.
We don't have a fundamental
energy shortage, which is the
complete reverse of the way
we've always had this
discussion.
Why do you need to conserve
energy and switch everything?
Or we'll say to Chinese that
they can't have standards of
living that we've all
become-- there is
no shortage of energy.
We've just got to accept that
we're going to use different
technologies.
The reality is that since the
anti-nuclear movement really
came up in the early 1970s,
maybe a bit earlier, the US
has invested in 150 new
coal-fired power stations.
So every single nuclear plant
that was proposed and then
canceled because of anti-nuclear
activism either
was replaced by a coal plant
right there, and in some
places they actually tore out
the places where the reactors
were going to put, and they put
coal boilers in the exact
same locations or
somewhere else.
And so the environmental
movement has made the world
safe for coal, unintentionally
of course, and somehow now has
to look to a future where they
want to eliminate coal, just
as the rest of the world--
Asia, China, India, so on---
getting to the standard of
living or hoping to get to the
standard of living in energy
consumption that the US and
everyone else put in
some time ago.
ROBERT STONE: We're starting to
realize real costs for not
dealing with climate change.
Hurricane Sandy, I think,
has cost $60 billion.
What if we get another
one next year?
I mean, that could happen.
The catastrophic pollution
that's going on in Beijing
right now--
there are costs that are
starting to emerge from not
tackling this problem.
STEWART BRAND: A lot of the
environmental movement that
took shape then was one, leftist
and two, romantic.
It was part of the hippie
counterculture thing, which I
was part of.
And so ideology and romanticism
encourage you to
basically have a narrative
and a few notions.
And then everything fits
into that narrative.
It doesn't work with
climate change.
With climate change and with
greenhouse gases, you've got
to work back from
the solution.
My fellow environmentalists have
this romantic attachment
to a certain view of the world,
which does not fit with
actually dealing with the
engineering problem
[INAUDIBLE]
address.
ERIC SCHMIDT: But isn't there
another problem, which is
people are loath to change their
minds and admit that
they were wrong?
And you all each, actually,
in the movie say,
this is what I thought.
Some new data came along,
and I changed my mind.
ROBERT STONE: I actually
don't agree with that.
ERIC SCHMIDT: No, you don't
agree with that?
Go ahead.
STEWART BRAND: This is the
difference between
evidence-driven and
ideology-driven, is ideology,
you double down on your theory
of the world, even thought
it's wrong.
ROBERT STONE: Most documentaries
function and are
marketed and have a life out
in the world by reinforcing
people's preconceptions
about the world.
What we've done here with
this movie is to
take a different tack.
And it's not like coming at you
in your face and saying,
oh, you're wrong.
This is why you're wrong.
It's we are you.
And we were wrong about
some things.
And we were wrong for a whole
variety of reasons, because we
were given information
that was wrong.
And so it takes you
on a journey.
But what I found--
and this was one of the
surprises that came out of
showing it at Sundance--
is that it actually--
it's like in a religious
conversion.
It's actually a really--
I don't know if the right
word is enjoyable.
It's a cathartic experience.
It's actually a more satisfying
experience than
being told what you
already believe.
Like, that's nice to be
told, oh, I'm right.
But it's actually even more
exhilarating to have your mind
changed-- or no, not to have
your mind changed but to
change your mind, to come to
your own conclusions about
something based on
new information.
You have to look at the worst
case scenarios that have
happened with even the most
ridiculously designed reactor
ever built, which is the
one at Chernobyl.
The worst-case scenario turns
out to be not the apocalypse
that we all thought it was.
I trust the United Nations and
the World Health Organization
that's done the definitive
studies on this.
And their conclusion is that
Chernobyl has killed 56
people, which was probably the
most astonishing fact I came
across in making
the whole film.
So if you look at all of the
various ways that we produce
energy and figure out the deaths
per terawatt, how many
people die per unit of energy
produced, nuclear is the
second safest after wind.
It's even safer than
solar panels, as we
point out in the film.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Because people
fall off the solar panels.
ROBERT STONE: Well, no, it's
actually making solar panels
is a toxic process.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Really?
ROBERT STONE: The materials,
the cadmium and lithium and
all these things, right?
So the safety thing, we
can obviously make
reactors much safer.
And we show that in the film--
new types of reactors that are
passively safe, that they
don't have all these
redundancies built into
them, because
they're inherently unsafe.
But even the reactors
that are--
these gargantuan things that
were sort of a crazy thing to
be built, anyway--
have turned out to be
remarkably safe.
GWYNETH CRAVENS: I just wanted
to add one thing that changed
my mind about nuclear power,
which was visiting nuclear
plants and another nuclear
facilities and nuclear waste
repositories and so on.
Seeing it for yourself, you
realize how many barriers
there are between the public and
the radioactive material.
And if people were more used
to these plants, which look
formidable in the distance
because of their giant cooling
towers and stuff, if people were
educated early on about
how nuclear power worked and
what radiation can and cannot
do, I think that would
help significantly.
ROBERT STONE: Well, one of the
main stories in the film is
the development of the integral
fast reactor, which
was a reactor that was developed
in the late '80s and
early '90s in the United States,
where they set out to
really solve a lot of
the basic problems
with nuclear power.
And one of the key
ones was safety.
And this was a reactor
that was--
they tried to melt it down.
We have film of it, and those
of you who haven't seen the
film, there's film of
them trying to melt
the thing down twice.
They ran through shutting off
all the safety devices, just
letting the thing completely
run wild, and sitting back,
not touching anything, not
touching the dials.
And the thing just passively
shut itself down.
As it got hotter, the reactivity
diminished and it
shut itself down.
So this was a reactor that we
developed that does have these
kind of advance passive safety
devices or designs that are a
central part of fourth
generation reactors.
And it was killed really
for political reasons.
So nobody here is advocating us
ever building the kinds of
reactors that caused Chernobyl
or caused Fukushima or
anything like that.
What we're advocating for is
innovation and R&D on advanced
designs that don't have these
kind of problems.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Look at
aviation today.
The recent statistics are
that aviation, flown by
professional pilots and
commercial airlines, both
globally and in the United
States, is the safest it has
ever been since the
introduction
of commercial flight.
That is the progress of 50
years of smart people,
regulators, reproducible
designs, competitive
financing, lots and lots of
learning, investigations, all
those kinds of things.
The fact of the matter is you
put enough airplanes in the
air, at least one of them
is going to crash.
But if you can then design in
such a way that crash didn't,
you improve it.
And I think we have to get
to that conversation.
Facts actually do change.
Data--
we do actually learn things.
Society does actually change.
And I think as a result of this
conversation, I'm now
quite convinced that the problem
is not a fact-based
one, it's a trust-based
one, that I think
Stewart, you said it right.
The dialogue really sort
of named that.
Because until there's some basic
trust by the average
person that the smart people,
representing by you guys, are
going to do the right thing or
the governments or something,
we're going to be in this
quagmire for, in my
view, far too long.
And I think we have an
opportunity with some of these
new technological ideas to
actually have a real
breakthrough.
It'd be nice if we actually got
that and we got it before
we destroyed the planet.